All right,
we're doing a quick hit today to help highlight someone who's fighting these
insane lockdowns as hopefully you are in your own little way.
I'll be sitting down with Anton, the owner of Nick,
the Greek restaurant in Ventura County.
And you probably recognize him because he's the guy who stood up to government
regulators trying to shut down his business.
I'm going to throw to the viral video that has been seen millions of times
already. And then we're going to go right into my interview with Anton.
So first take a look at the video.
I'm aware of
[inaudible] I'm allowed to do I've put tables outside. I sold all my food to go.
I didn't, I didn't do any
[inaudible] that you guys, when we start the lawsuit
against the health department.
[Inaudible].
It's all right, Anton, we just showed the viral clip.
It's very obvious to me that not all heroes wear capes. You stood up to the man,
man. How you feeling?
Uh, yeah, it did. Um, uh, I mean that, that, that video was not,
I had no intention of that video going viral is that was,
that was literally just my emotion in the time, um, that that happened.
And it was just, just so happened to be that, that guy, the guy, Jorge Ventura,
I was just coming out of an interview with him. Um,
and those health inspectors were there. So, um,
as my reaction came out with alpha inspectors, he, uh,
he was filming the whole video and that that's how it went viral. Um,
there's two inspectors at that, that were there. There was a lady and a guy, uh,
my strong feeling is if, if it was just the lady there,
it would have gone a completely different way. Um,
and just because she was very calm,
she was really trying to get the facts and figure out everything that was going
on. Um, and even in the beginning sounded like she was like, okay, like,
let me try to figure this out to like help you out type of thing.
Whereas when that guy opened his mouth, he just like, was this aggressed,
like he came across as this like aggressive macho person. Um,
and that really like, kind of set it off for me because I was like, excuse me,
like what, like what this doesn't make any sense. Um, and the main, the main,
the main thing, and the main thing with me is,
is I don't like when people don't stick to their word, right? So,
so the story started on last Friday,
I spoke to a supervisor at the health department and I was like, listen,
I'm going to put my tables out as a protest.
I'm still going to serve all my food to go.
I'm not going to actually serve people outside. I'm going to serve it all to go,
let me protest for whatever four hours that evening. Um, and, and just,
just let me do that. And I'm allowed to do that by law. Uh, uh,
right now you're allowed, you're allowed to protest. Um,
and he was fine with that. He was like, you know what,
if you're just going to do it for this evening and that night that's fine.
So I said, all right, great. Um, and this is when he didn't stick to his word,
because that evening around seven 30, uh,
two health inspectors came in and were like, listen,
we're going to have to give you a closure notice. And I'm like, look, look,
I understand that I'm not following the rules right now because I put my tables
outside, but it was as a protest. So let me take them inside right now.
And let's just bring it about all,
you don't need to give me a closure notice because I'm going to follow your
rules now. And they're like, okay, okay, let me talk to her. Let's talk to her.
Let me talk to our supervisors. So they call the supervisor, came back and said,
Nope, we still have to order you a closure notice.
And by this time I had already put all my tables inside and I'm like,
I'm following your rules now. Why are we seeing to go down this route? So, uh,
what ended up happening was you're like, yeah,
you're going to have to contact the health department to be able to reopening
it. And I said, well, today's Friday night.
You guys aren't open on Saturday and Sunday.
I'm not closing my rule for Saturday and Sunday cause I have bills to pay,
you know? Um, so, so I ended up leaving my business open, uh, Saturday,
Sunday, Monday morning, that same supervisor called me and I said, Hey, listen,
man, last time we talked, you didn't stick to your words.
I'm going to record this conversation, which is exactly what I did.
I recorded the conversation. And, um,
basically the conversation went to the fact where he was like, look,
if you put to me on an email that you're going to continue complying, uh,
you're going to continue to have your chairs and tables inside and continue to
serve only to go in for delivery is like, you can reel all reinstate you,
you can re reopen back again. I said, all right, well,
this time I'm filming and recording you. So you better keep your word.
He's like, yes I will. So I sent him that email a few minutes after I said,
look, I'm going to comply. Fine. Let me go about my business.
Let's just drop this whole thing. And two hours later, he, uh,
he comes back and Lemo says, actually, you know what?
Because we heard that you were open on Saturday and Sunday. Uh,
you're going to have for men closed now, God, I'm like, look.
And when I got that email, that's when I was ready.
Like this is the second time this guy is not stuck to his word. And he's again.
So, um, and that's the exact time that Jorge Ventura was interviewing me.
And that's the exact time was two health inspectors came in. So my, my,
my emotion was ready at its highest because of that email that came in.
So that's, that's how it went.
First off, basically,
the guy's lying to you and you have to stay open on the weekends because it's
hard enough to, to make ends meet at this point.
Was anyone even sitting at your tables outside? And again,
you weren't serving them out there. You were saying, okay, you take it to go.
And then there's a seat there. If you happen to sit there,
I think people are still allowed to sit outdoors,
but was anyone even using those seats?
Yeah. So on that I said, yeah, some people were sitting out on the,
on the table. Some people were sitting on a curb.
People were kind of sitting wherever they, wherever they could eat their food.
Um, and again, that's not that and the health department's like, well,
you're responsible for that. I don't feel,
and I am not responsible for other human beings.
I also don't have the right to go up to somebody and tell them what to do.
It's not in my, it's not my right at all.
So that's the whole point is like their, their,
their way of thinking is just out of this world. It makes no sense.
It's so I'm going to go around now and start telling people,
you can't do this and you can do that. And that it's not in my right. Yeah.
Like a very terrible government regulator. Obviously,
if you don't think that's it in your right.
So can you just talk about just generally,
like you got a smile on your face right now, but you,
you have to be seriously frustrated with what's going on here.
I know you have a couple of locations we ordered in for my whole team, from the,
uh, from the LA location and you guys make great food. Um,
can you just talk about just the, the general frustrations that you,
that all restaurants or all restaurant tours are feeling?
Well, I think the biggest frustration right now,
and the reason why people are really lashing out right now is because over the
summer, when they, when they shut everything down,
the government was giving money weekly to people. Well,
they were doing the PVP loans for businesses.
So everybody could continue on paying their bills because the economy is
continuing to move forward. This time around,
they're shutting down restaurants and they're not going to give us any PP money.
They're not going to help our employees out by giving them money weekly.
So it's like, well, how do you expect my employees to go pay for their rent?
How do you expect me to pay for my rent? I mean, it's just,
it's a chain reaction and a chain of fact, that's, that makes no sense.
And it's not fair at all, especially with big box stores.
And when you walk into any Costco, Lowe's home Depot, I mean,
there's a ton of people in there.
It really does not look like they're controlling that whole 20% occupied,
25% occupancy in those stores.
And it just so happens to be because those stores aren't controlled by the
health department,
restaurants are controlled by the health and which I also don't even know if
it's in their right to control the outdoor seating because health department is
supposed to be for the health of a or for the food and safety or the safety of
the food in a restaurant to make sure that people are not getting sick. Uh,
that's the job of the health department with a restaurant? Um,
not to go around saying you can't,
you can't have people sitting outside that's that's never been part of it.
Yeah.
Did you happen to see that video of the health inspector guy in,
in LA basically saying that we know that outdoor dining doesn't spread the
disease, but we just want to keep people at home.
Did you happen to catch that video?
Oh, no. I didn't say that. That's I didn't see it, but that makes, yeah, that's,
that's the whole thing.
It's not scientifically proven that outdoor dining at spreads COVID faster than,
than anything else. So, and that's the whole thing is,
is everyone just wants a level playing field, right. So it's like, okay,
if we're going to shut things out, shut everybody down. If you're not,
then don't shut everybody down and let us all continue. I mean, you, you can't,
again,
you can't have this unlevel playing field where we're all these other stores are
making a ton of money and we're not.
But having said that mom and pop like clothing stores that are on main
street in Ventura, they're feeling the revenue also dipping right now. Why?
Because people aren't coming downtown to eat.
So they're also not coming downtown to shop well, it's not only affecting us.
It's affecting retail, other retailers, you know.
Are you going to stay in, uh, in California?
That's the million dollar question that I get asked a hundred times a day.
But like, as a business guy, as someone trying to, you know,
do something good and put out a good product,
but having to deal with these guys, like,
do you think about getting out of here?
Yeah, I do. Um, I just have a growth plan for the restaurants right now within,
uh, within California. Um, and, and with everything going on,
I still hope that I can continue to, to hit it. Uh,
this is most likely going to hinder that, but, um,
if I am able to hit it most likely once I'm, once, once I've gotten,
once I've reached my goal, then I probably will be moving to a,
to a different state. Not unless California starts changing, but I mean,
you look at Elon Musk is, has moved. Tesla's moved, uh,
Oracle's moved all these. And, and the crazy thing to me is, is,
is I don't understand to see how, um, how,
how there all the money that's coming in to California because of these
companies. That's now not going to be because it's going somewhere.
As on all these people that were, they were employing. I mean,
how do they see the future going along? You know, it's really tough.
Well, listen, man, I know you didn't ask for this fight, but you're in it now.
And anything I can do to help just let me know.
One more thing I want to say is, um, the,
the officials that are controlling things right now are the same type of people,
which I find completely ridiculous as when,
back when they tried to shut Tesla down.
And there was that government official leader and said, Elon Musk, or you,
Ron Mars, like who does that?
Especially if you're trying to portray yourself in a leadership position,
you don't do that. I mean, and that's basically,
those are the type of people that are trying to us, like that's, it's,
it's completely out of this world and ridiculous, in my opinion.
Anton, you want to run for governor. People want me to run for governor?
I feel like, I feel like you're better suited.
I don't think I don't.
I don't think I can take that on man politics as a whole different,
a different ball game.
I'll I'll stick to be a business of being an entrepreneur.
All right. Stick to the falafel in the meantime. All right. Well listen.
Anything, anything I can do to help? I'm not just saying it. You got my number.
So just let me know and we'll just keep the spotlight on you guys.
And I wish you luck.
Dave one, sorry.
This is really the last thing I want to say is saying anything that you can do
to help. What I'd love for you to do is, uh, because we've gone viral,
we've got so much support from literally people in different States,
calling in and ordering food to support us, and also trying to donate.
If you could go out and tell all of the us and these same people,
Hey, listen,
don't only do that to Nick the Greek start calling up random restaurants in
California and do those good deeds to all the restaurants. Cause again,
my whole point from the get-go was to help restaurants as a whole.
This wasn't for me and this wasn't for Nick, the Greek.
This is for the whole thing.
So if all these people can call a random restaurants in California and just
start ordering food, I mean, that'd be, that'd be amazing.
And that's how you can help spread that because you have the audience. So.
I'm on it, man. You're a true American. Thanks for taking the time. Now,
get back to work for God's sakes.
All right. See ya.
If you're looking for more honest and thoughtful conversations about politics,
instead of nonstop, yelling out our politics playlist.
And if you want to watch full interviews on a variety of topics,
watch our full episode playlist, all right, over here,
and to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and click the notification bell.